Herkese merhaba ben Birdal 17 yaşındayım
ve 4 senedir iklim aktivisti yim iklim
aktivist liği yaptığım ekipler arasında
you for clim Türkiye fridays for Future
He for She ve un wom ekipleri var Ben
bugün sizlere küçükken hayatımdan müziği
eksik etmezken iklim aktivisti olduğumda
bunu nasıl bir araç olarak
kullandığımdan
bahsedeceğim Ben küçükken neredeyse 67
yaşlarındayken dedemle beraber Radyo
dinleyip şarkı söylemeyi seven bir
çocuktum Sabahları En Sevdiğim şarkıyı
dinlemek için erkenden kalkar koşarak
salonun yolunu tutup televizyonu açıp en
sevdiğim şarkının televizyonda çıkmasını
beklerdim bu şarkının
sahibi genç kadınların ve kızların
şarkılarıyla
yüreklendirmek
şimdi diyeceksiniz
E işte iklim akisin işte Gran bahsetmen
gerekiyor
işte neden açık Radyodaki
[Müzik]
çağrıdır bu
konuda
müzik yaşanmışlıkların ses tonudur
gittiğiniz yer yaşadığınız anı Kısacası
yaşanmışlıkların arka tonudur Bu yüzden
ben de iklim grevlerinde genel olarak
Eee iklim krizinde iklim krizine işte
müzik olarak yer vermeye
çalışıyorum burada 15 Mart iklim grev
imiz Bu ilk iklim için okul grevi
çağrısıyla görevlerimiz de konser ve
forumlar olarak insanlara bilinçlendirme
ve iklim krizi
konusunda şarkılar üzerinden anlatmayı
hedefliyoruz Bu da 24 mayıs'taki 2
Türkiye'deki 2 iklim
grevi ve o grevde çocukların yanında ilk
defa liseliler de yer almıştı ve
sonrasında zaten 15 Mart'tan sonra bu
hareket kitlesel bir çağrı ve hareket
olarak
Eee devam etmişti Bu da 20 Eylül
2019'daki iklim grev imiz bu iklim
grevinde konserlerimiz yapmıştık ve
forumlar mızı
gerçekleştirmiştik Bu da 2019'da
yaptığımız ilk konserde etkinliğimiz
olmuştu
[Müzik]
Aslında benim hikayem şu şekilde
başlamıştı Ağustos 2018'de greta'nın
Eee parlamentonun önünde iklim iklim
için atılması gereken acil ve temel
talepleri Cuma günü Okuldan çıkıp daha
doğrusu bazen Okula da gitmeyip oturma
eylemi yaparak karar vericilere
endişesini e taleplerini ve korkularını
Dile getirmek için bu şekilde bir eylem
göstermesi haberi benim karşıma çıkmıştı
ve ç
etkilenmiştim
sonrasında
bazen işte o zamanlar 7 sınıftaydım ve
fen dersinde Koskocaman bir yok oluşu 3
cümleyle kısa bir paragraf şeklinde
iklim değişikliği olarak anlatılması
bana çok adaletsizce gelmişti Çünkü
Koskocaman bir yok oluşu benim gibi
karşımdaki insanlar nasıl
endişeyle endişe sahibi olacaklardı
benim korkularımı nasıl yaşayacaklardır
geleceğe karşı benim gibi nasıl
endişeleri olacaktı o zaman öğretmenime
çok sinirlenmiştim ve hayal kırıklığına
uğramıştım bu konuda nasıl harekete
geçemez gerçekleri nasıl söylemez
diye ama
sonrasında şu söz her zaman aklımdan
çıkmaz bizi Duyabiliyor
musunuz bazen Sesimin duyulmadığı
zannettiğim zamanlar ya da
gerildiğimde taleplerimi ilettiğim zaman
en azından bir kişiye bile ulaşmışsa bu
benim zaferimdir
ama şunu söyleyebilirim
ki açık radyoda 2000 2019 un
yazından 15 Mart çağrısını duymuştum
greta'nın yaptığı ilk çağrıyı greta'nın
yaptığı ilk çağrıyla birlikte benim de
harekete geçme sebebim olmuştu greta'nın
çağrısından sonra yine arkadaşım atlasın
çağrısı ile birlikte 15 Mart'ta bebek
parkında çocuk ve gençlerle birlikte
bebek parkında geleceğimiz için
yürümüştük ve 15 Mart'ın sonunda bir iki
hafta sonrası diyebiliriz
tüm Çocuklar ve gençler harekete geçerek
kitlesel bir hareket oluşturmuştur bu
kitlesel hareket nedeniyle iklim krizi
farkındalığı artmış ve bir sonraki
grevler daha fazla kalabalık ve
farkındalığı artmış bir şekilde devam
etmişti her şeyin başladığı o günü asla
unutmuyorum şu kareyi görüyorsanız o
karede hepimiz toplanmış ve ilk iklim
için okul grev imizi
yapmıştık o gün dedim ki ben asla
durmayacağım ve 4 sene oldu hala da
durmuyorum ve durmaya da pek niyetim yok
açıkçası
her zaman şu soruyu aklıma getiriyorum
benim elimden ne gelebilir ben ne
yapabilirim Bu kriz için nasıl mücadele
edebilirim diye devam
sordum araştırdım bazen iklim haberleri
konusunda Stresten ağladığım zamanlar
bile olmuş olabiliyor sonrasında
2019'da 24
[Müzik]
Mayıs 20
Eylül ve gerçekleştirdiğimiz takas
şenliğinden sonra 2019'u 4 grevle
kapatmıştı 2020'de maalesef pandem minin
getirdiği pandem minin gelmesi nedeniyle
Biz evlere kapandık ve evlere
kapanmamızı nasıl çözebiliriz nasıl
devam edebiliriz nasıl harekete
geçebiliriz bu konuda bizim elimizden ne
gelebilir nasıl devam edebilir Sonuçta
evden dışarı çıkamıyoruz sokakta
megafonla bir basın açıklaması ya da bir
slogan atamıyoruz E peki ne yapacağız
dedik en azından şu an kullanılan
platformlarla devam edelim canlı
yayınlar yapalım paneller düzenleyelim
online konuşmalar ve konserler yapalım
ve kitlesel
toplantılarda Online olarak pankartları
alıp Zoom üzerinden fotoğraflar
çekilelim En azından grev yaptığımızı ve
birlikte olduğumuz anlaşılsın
dedik devam ettikçe Anladık ki biz En
azından denedik
harekete geçmek için
insanları ilerlemeye davet ediyoruz ve
bu konuda mücadeleye davet ediyoruz
2021'de anka kuşu gibi küllerimizden
doğarak for clim Türkiye'yi kurduk yani
iklim için gençlik
Türkiye'yi 19 Mart'ta ilk iklim grev
imizi yaptık hem 2021 ilk grevi hem
de iklim grevi olmuş oldu bu konuda da
biz çok
heyecanlanmıştım
şimdi müzik endüstrisinin iklim krizine
olan etkisine Gelecek
olursak şu an konserler karbon nötür
ve sıfır Karbon ayak iizi temalı
turneler düzenliyor ünlü sanatçılar ve
müzisyenler Bu yüzden iklim krizinin
müzik endüstrisindeki etkisi bize her
zaman
hem farkındalığa hem de en azından
gezegenimize saygılı olduğumuzu
gösteriyor biz 19 Mart'tan sonra tüm
grevler imize konserleri ve panelleri de
eklemeye başladık Çünkü
müzik
BT müzik Evrensel ve birleştiricidir ve
bu felsefeyle
birlikte bu felsefeyle birlikte Friday
for Future yani gelecek için cumalar
greta'nın kurduğu gelecek için cumalar
hareketinde
eee
organizatörleri geliştirerek
bir MZ iklim için müzik hareketini
kurdular ve müzik üzerinden iklim
grevlerini anlatmaya ve farkındalık
yaymaya çalışmıştık Türkiye'de de aynı
şekilde Biz de 19 Mart'tan sonra iklim
grevler imizde Eee Farkındalık yaratmak
için grevler imize konser ve forumları
eklemeye başlamıştık
Bu da konserlerimiz
konserimiz bir sahne ve burada müz
sede 24 Eylül'deki iklim grevdeki
konserimiz katılımcıların olduğu E bir
fotoğraf bu aslında görünen tarafı bir
de izlemeye gelen çok sonradan gelen
insanlar da vardı ve birlikte iklim için
hareket edince ne kadar güçlü olduğumuzu
ve bunun için en azından harekete
geçebildiği İnsanların bu konuda
farkındalık yaratabileceğini görmüş
olduk ve bu konuda Eee iklim
aktivistleri olarak Harekete Geçmek
bizim için çok önemli ve harekete
geçirebilmek her gref iklim için e
sesimizi ve taleplerimizi
duyurabilir ve değişim yaratabileceğiniz
de inanıyorum Peki siz gelecek
iklim hareketi
üzerinden nasıl bireysel olarak hareket
edebilirsiniz bunun çözümü aslında çok
basit çözümün bir parçası olacağız Ama
şöyle bir sıkıntı var ki iklim için tek
bir çözüm kaynağı yok yani Keşke sihirli
bir değneğim olsa dünyaya tutabilsem
işte tüm krizler yok Olsa ve Bu kriz
üzerinden işte hayatlarımız düzgünce
ilerlese ve
kurtulabilsem için herkes elini taşın
altına koymak
zorunda bu konuda harekete geçmek için
ilk önce Sürdürülebilir ve iklim
dostluğu hedefler için ve günlük
yaşantımızda bunları
uygulayabilme
uygulayabilmek gerekiyor Bu konuda güzel
bir Haberimiz var Haziran
2021 2021'de iklim hareketi olarak Milli
Eğitim Bakanlığı'na iklim krizinin bir
ders olarak anlatılmasını istedik ve bu
konuda talebimiz geri çevrilmedi ve bu
konuda Eee iklim krizi Türkiye'de bir
ders olarak Entegre edilecek
ve iklim krizine eğitim olarak yer veren
ülkelerden bir tanesi de biz olacağız Bu
da hem gençlerin bu konuda farkındalık
yaratmasını istediği ve harekete geçmek
istediği ve bu konuda krizin yıkıcı
önlemlerin yıkıcı risklerini ve
önlemlerini öğrenmeleri için güzel bir
fırsat olacaktı Bunun dışında bilim
adamların Bilim insanlarının
Eee Bilim insanlarının sözlerini
dinlemek
araştırmak Ondan sonra Risk almak ve
bunun
dışında Harekete Geçmek ve teşvik etmek
çok önemli bu
konuda araştırma yapmak ve bu konu
destek
çıkılması çok
önemli
Şimdi ise benim için en önemli olan
kısım kolektif bir risk altında
olduğumuzu bilmek ve bu konuda iş
insanlarının ve çalışma alanlarınız
dışında Konfor alanlarınız çıkarak iklim
için nasıl harekete geçebileceğiniz
anlatmak yani iş alanlarınızda iklim
krizini nasıl anlatabiliriz bunu
göstermek beni Özlem Tekin etkiledi Ama
sizi bir şarkıcı bir gazeteci bir yazar
ya da Eee tasarımcı etkileyebilir kendi
yaratmak istediğiniz geleceğin öncüsü
olabilirsiniz değişime yaratmak bize
bağlı ve bu konuda Harekete Geçmek ve
harekete
geçirmekte bizim elimizde Çünkü Buna çok
ihtiyacımız var beni dinlediğiniz için
teşekkür
[Alkış]
ederim